5 13 on your friday morning while the
los angeles dodgers in a tough fight for
the national league pennant with the
atlanta braves i'm a huge dodger fan
i rewrote the lyrics to a 1970 song and
named it after dodger superstar mookie
betts
well the host of the dodgers post game
radio show david vasey was kind enough
to play that song
following la's blowout win over the
braves wednesday night take a listen
i promised nathan tanebaum who's a big
dodger fan living in las vegas
who listens to the show that if the
dodgers won today
i would play his mookie bets parody song
of the old time
spooky song by the atlanta rhythm
section
here it goes
when everything is getting kind of
moving
the dodgers get together and opponents
start to feel a little spooky
first they say whoa this doesn't feel
quite right
and then they stop and say
good night dodger baseball's kind of
crazy
uh so much fun to write that song and to
have it played on the radio was a hoot
and a half of course the song spooky
from the 1970s was a big hit so
thanks to the dodgers for uh playing the
song now they just got to get back on
the winning track johnny oh well
that was one game right so what what's
the series well they're down
three games to one oh